did there come a time that you ended up
having to go on a press tour for the rum
diary
we i got a call for the rum diary press
tour in
the fall of 2011. so that's close to two
two and a half years after you filmed
um
i'm an actress not a mathematician for a
reason
roughly yes okay and um
could you please describe for the jury
what a press tour is just explain it to
him well you take a
a movie once it's completed and
if it doesn't have distribution you as
part of the promotion of that movie you
go to these various places
normally cities
like london or
new york and you
do press events in those cities to kind
of promote the film and you go to place
to place talking about the film
and so
you were then called to participate in
the press tour for the rome diary
uh yes i had um just
i was going i had just finished going
through the process of uh separation
with my former partner
and i was moving and
going through that and i got a phone
call saying
remember that movie you did in puerto
rico well they want you for the
press tour and
i said well perfect timing
and we did that i think october late
october 2011. okay
so describe for the jury your
interactions with mr depp during the
press tour
well on the
first stop of the first stop the
beginning of the tour was los angeles
where we both lived and
we did a press day
normal press day and then at the end of
it
i was
invited uh by johnny to come up to his
room
to have a drink with uh him and the
director
of the film
and i
went up to the room um to see both him
and bruce um but
as soon as i got there johnny said bruce
wasn't going to make it so i stayed
johnny and i started talking
i told he asked me about my relationship
i said well you know i'm going
going through it um
i'm going through the separation right
now and it's been
you know rough couple of months but
that's normal and he said well that same
with
same with me you know it's been
i can't remember exactly how long he
said it had been but that he had split
from the mother of his kids and
uh said that he understood so uh on the
on the couch we we talked finished some
wine and then i got up and left and as i
went to leave
he
grabbed both sides of my face
similar to what he did
in
in puerto rico and we were filming that
scene
and
he kissed me and i kissed him back
and
what happened next with respect to any
relationship with mr depp
well then we fell in love
we went on this press tour
i think in london he sat
had me sat next to him at this at a
dinner and then we ended up spending the
night together in my hotel room
and
for the rest of the
press tour we were
it was on i'll put it that way
once we were back from the press tour
you know we had this
you know whirlwind romance kind of just
in these like beautiful places all over
and
we're falling in love and not able to
really show it because um
he wasn't
that the world didn't know about the
split between he and his former partner
and of course um
some woman i was like is that
troubling you know and i i'd ask him
no you know he swore to me that they
hadn't even shared a bed for a year and
that they were but they were protecting
the kids and not publicizing it so or
not making it known to the press and so
we kind of had to be a little bit under
the radar not a little bit we had to be
really under the radar
um because as johnny pointed out that
the world would
blame me
um and call me a homewrecker uh even
though i had nothing to do with it
so we were secretly dating and then
you know it was it was it was beautiful
it was um
i
felt like
this man
knew me and saw me in a way that no one
else had
i felt he understood me i felt he
understood
where i came from i i felt like
i felt that like when i was around
johnny i felt like the most beautiful
person in the world
you know made me feel seen made me feel
like a million dollars
and
that kind of
feeling where you know he just lavish
gifts and lavish expressions of love and
how he had never met a woman like me i
mean i remember he took
the foil off of the
off of this uh bottle and put it on my
ring finger and i had only been with him
like
days you know or maybe maybe it was
weeks at the time yeah it was probably
about a few weeks but it just felt very
intense
but we weren't doing normal life stuff
we weren't like
stuck in traffic with each other we
weren't going to the grocery store and
doing life we were like
hiding in these places
around the world he had a lot of he has
so many homes and so we'd be in one of
those homes or my home at the time and
it would be like a bubble like a ins
like we were in this little bubble of
secrecy and it felt like a warm glow as
we would say
just music and and the kind of books
that we both loved and
poetry that we both knew by heart and it
it was um
it felt like an
it felt like a dream
it felt like
absolute magic